[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBERT GINDA: Thank you for
joining us here at I/O today.
Hello everyone on the
Livestream as well.
My name is Rob.
I'm an Engineering Lead on
the Android Things Team,
and I'm joined today
by Shikha, who is
a Product Manager on our team.
This is a Lenovo Smart Display
built using Android Things.
You can think of it as a
visual Google Assistant
or like a smart
speaker with a display.
You probably heard
in the keynote
already, or maybe
in Vince's talk
earlier today, that
these devices, and others
from JBL and LG, will
be available on store
shelves starting this July, just
a couple of months from now.
Today, we're going to
tell you the story of how
we built these
devices from prototype
up to the production
devices that will
be available in a few months.
Before joining the
Android Things team,
I spent most of
my career writing
software that ran on other
people's devices, probably
like many of you.
But building a new piece
of hardware at scale
is different from the kind
of work I had done before,
and it came with a
lot of new challenges.
And today, we're going to
tell you about some of them.
Our hope is that you leave this
talk with a better idea of what
it's like to build
consumer hardware at scale
and how Android Things makes
it easier than it's ever been.
It's not that scary once
you know what to expect.
So I hope that our story
of prototype to production
can help you build a
device of your own.
SHIKHA KAPOOR: If you are a
software developer thinking
about building
consumer devices, here
are a few things you
probably care about.
First, you want to build
your product features
without having to worry about
the underlying platform.
You also want to be able to
swap out underlying hardware
seamlessly, without affecting
your application layer,
as the technology or product
needs evolve over time.
You obviously want your
devices to be secure.
I think it's obvious why
security is increasingly
an essential requirement
for smart devices.
They hold the keys to our homes
and our personal information.
What's probably
less obvious is why
it's hard to provide
this kind of security.
It's incredibly expensive to
harden products out of the gate
and to keep them
updated over time.
Meanwhile, there's immense cost
pressure from end customers,
and it's hard to amortize
costs with that large volume.
We know this at Google,
since we've been
doing this for many products.
Coming back to you.
Finally, if you are
building a consumer device,
you'd want to manage release
and update channels over time.
Android Things was designed
with all of these needs in mind.
We provide turnkey
hardware in the form
of pre-certified
system on modules
or are what we call the SoMs.
The SoM includes the CPU,
Wi-Fi, Bluetooth, memory,
and other critical
hardware components.
Think of this as a
small computing platform
that you can use to build
a variety of IoT devices.
We bring up the operating
system on new SoMs,
test it, and certify
its suitability
for production
devices so that you
don't have to do any of this.
Later on in the
talk, we'll give you
an inside look into
some of this work
that Google handles for you.
You'll provide the
application code
and wire up the peripherals, and
Google takes care of the rest.
What do you see here are smart
displays from Lenovo, LG,
and JBL.
As Rob mentioned, they are
built using Android Things.
In fact, if you
look under the hood,
all three products have the
same SoM, which is pretty cool.
These devices have
far field microphones
that can hear you from
the other side of the room
and built-in speakers that can
answer back across the room,
just like a smart speaker.
But now, we also
have a touch screen,
which makes it possible
to see visual results.
This is quite
cool, if the result
happens to be a list
of restaurant nearbys
or a map showing you
your commute conditions.
We announced this
earlier this year at CES,
and we're very proud of
the reception we received.
Let's dive a little deeper
and see how they built these.
About a year back,
we at Google were
wondering if we could build
a visual Google Assistant.
This would enable
deep integration
with other Google services,
such as YouTube, Photos, Maps,
and so on.
Building a consumer
device, though,
is typically a long process.
But for a fast-evolving space
like smart home devices,
time to market is
extremely important.
We want a quick turnaround
time, and this is exactly where
Android Things shines.
Our goal is to make it possible
for software developers like
you to build consumer
devices at scale.
But that's a hard thing
to get right in a vacuum.
It takes real-world experience
in building and shipping
a lot of devices to know
that you've really done It.
This project would give us the
perfect opportunity to do that.
In this case, our customers
were software developers
from other internal teams at
Google, such as the Google
Assistant team.
For small displays,
while they took the lead
on building
application software,
we iterated on the platform.
As a result, we were able
to get these from prototype
to production super fast, and
we now have a stronger platform
for you to build on.
We started by building some
proof-of-concept hardware
for Smart Displays.
Our goal was to learn from
that and to use the device
to kick off broader
discussions across the company.
So we took a few weeks and some
spare parts and built this.
ROBERT GINDA: This is our first
proof-of-concept hardware.
This is running on some hardware
that we had used previously
to deliver an Android Things
powered smart speaker.
I built this case
with my son, cost me
about two Pokemon cards.
He still wonders when he's going
to get his bricks back, though.
This device doesn't have all
of the hardware that ships
on the final devices.
For example, it's
missing a camera.
It doesn't have the
Volume Up Down buttons,
or mute of any sort.
But that wasn't the
point of this device.
For this one, what
we were trying to do
is show just the basics of what
we thought we could achieve on
with the smart
display product to get
some conversations started.
The mic on this
one, in particular,
was kind of tricky to use.
It wasn't meant for
this kind of use case.
It needed a quiet
room, and you had
to stand in just the
right sweet spot.
But with a little
bit of practice,
it was possible to pull off a
pretty convincing demo with it.
On top of the Android
Things platform
and the smart speaker
code that we already had,
we built a small
Android application
to drive the
display and show off
some of the key use
cases we thought
were going to be important
for this kind of device.
One of the first things
we did with the display
is to transcribe your
query as you spoke it.
It was a basic proof that
the whole speech recognition
pipeline was up and
running properly,
and it looked pretty
cool in the demo.
Next up, we added some
support for rudimentary--
what we call a
knowledge card-- that
will show a brief
snippet of text
and a photo, along with
answers to certain questions.
This device couldn't
play video yet
because it didn't have the
hardware required for that.
But it could stream
music already,
just like a smart speaker.
So we added title track display
and media transport controls,
like pause and skip.
And then finally,
we took a rough cut
at the ambient screen, which
is what the device does when
it's not doing anything else.
It showed a photo slideshow
and a weather forecast.
So like I said, just kind of
a basic set of functionality
that we could use to show
people what we thought
we could build out of this.
It only took about two weeks
and a small team of people
to get this working.
But the result was
actually surprisingly close
to the architecture of
the final products that
are shipping in a few months.
The changes between
what we built here
and what we're shipping are
basically incremental changes.
Fundamentally, what we built
and what we're shipping
involves the smart
display application
at the top of the stack,
running on top of Android Things
on top of a certified
what we call a SoM.
Android Things
brings the hardware
supports, the security,
the application framework,
and the update mechanism, while
the smart display application
brings all over the Google
Assistant integration
and the visuals for the device.
Don't get me wrong.
There was definitely a lot
of work to do between here
and what we're
shipping this summer.
But as I said, the fundamental
architecture is the same,
and it was a matter of
incrementally building out
the feature set from here.
We practiced the demo
routine with this device,
and set up meetings across
Google over the next few weeks.
People got a kick out of the
brick case that we built.
And we had a lot of
great discussions
and some debate about product
features we should support,
about Android Things, and
about what we should do next.
Overall, the demos
went really well.
And we got the buy-in that we
needed from key stakeholders
across Google to move on to the
next step with this project.
SHIKHA KAPOOR: Now that
this was going to be real,
we kicked off a few
steps in parallel
to scale up our efforts.
First, our business
development team
started discussing discussions
with potential OEM partners.
In this case, an OEM,
or an Original Equipment
Manufacturer, refers
to a company that
will build and sell the device.
They come up with the industrial
design and the physical look
and feel of the product.
They are also pick parts like
the display camera, microphone,
and other audio components.
If you want to build a
device on Android Things,
you'll be the one responsible
for case design and component
selection.
In place of this step, you might
find an industrial design work
from to work with and a
factory to build your product.
A lot of details here were
handled by our OEM partners,
and we are not going
to cover them today.
In parallel, we started
finalizing the hardware
requirements for the product.
The proof of concept device
used to SoM that we had
used to build smart speakers.
But you can tell
anything else from it.
That has similar
requirements as well.
For smart displays,
though, we needed
something more
powerful to support use
cases, such as video playback.
Fortunately, we had some
SoM options in a roadmap
that we started evaluating.
Finally, in parallel to the OEM
selection and sound selection,
we got started on the
application software.
Google had already built out
the system backend and client
software for smart speakers.
But turning a smart speaker
into a smart display
isn't just a matter of
plugging in a touch panel.
There's a lot of new
work around the home
screen, the video playback
experience, the Maps and Photos
integration, and essentially
all the other visual features
that we were trying
to build with this.
Turning the application software
from a humble proof-of-concept
device into a
production device was
going to take a lot of time.
Most of the software
work was responsibility
of developers outside our team.
And they needed to get
started right away.
These engineers, who are
software developers like many
of you, don't want
to have to think
about the underlying
platform or the hardware.
But because we are building
this on Android Things,
they don't need to.
Like we mentioned earlier,
we can be [? coupled into. ?]
The application
engineers work on top
of the Android framework, just
like any Android developer
would.
Their application can run on
any hardware with Android Things
support.
So at this point in the
project, it's July of last year.
We're about a month and
a half into the work.
We've got our
proof-of-concept hardware.
We've got some business
development work underway.
We've got the hardware
selection underway,
and we're nearly
ready to get started
on the application software
development in earnest.
But in order to really
kickstart development,
we need to get some
actual hardware
into the hands of engineers
and product managers
and other folks at Google
who are going to actually
build this out.
But as we said
before, the hardware
that we used in that
proof-of-concept device
was just a little too slow to
use for more than just a demo.
So we looked through the SoMs
that we had in our pipeline
and found one that met the
requirements for this category
of devices, and it
happened to also
be very easy to buy in
quantity over the Internet.
And we had Android Things
already kind of running
pretty well on it.
So we decided to use
this as the basis
for some provisional
hardware that we
would build to unblock the
application engineers so
that they could get
started on their job
while we finished out
the hardware bring up.
We knew that we would
swap this hardware out
later when it got
closer to production,
but that didn't worry us,
because as we've said,
we're building on
Android Things,
and that gives you the isolation
from the hardware that you
need to be able to do that.
The second problem
we had, though,
with the provisional
hardware was
that it was a development
board kit, similar to the IMX 7
kits that we're giving
out here at I/O,
which means that it had a
display and a camera connected
to the baseboard through
flat flex ribbon cables.
You can, obviously,
work like this,
but it's a little
difficult to manage
if you have more than one
on your desk, for example.
And we wanted to give these
out to a lot of Googlers.
For the first few weeks,
we literally held the thing
together at our desks with
cardboard and rubber bands,
but that wasn't going
to scale to the quantity
that we wanted to deliver.
For that, we needed a
more solid enclosure
to keep everything in one spot.
And by the way, if you do
complete the scavenger hunt
here at I/O and you
get an IMAX 7 kit,
make sure to keep the packaging.
It turns into a handy
stand, so you don't
have to build one yourself.
So this is the
enclosure we came up
with for our first
provisional hardware.
Honestly, Android
Things didn't really
help or hurt either way in
the building of this case.
But I had a lot
of fun making it,
and I learned a
lot in the process.
So I hope you don't mind if
I geek out for a few minutes
and tell you a little bit
more about this design
and how we built it.
It looks pretty
plain from the front.
The point is that
it's just enough
to keep the hardware
together and give you
a rough sense of the form
factor that we had in mind.
There is a camera
module at the top.
Some microphones, that we
had manufactured locally here
in Mountain View, in
the middle of the top.
And of course the big
touch screen in the front.
Here's a quick view of the back.
The SoM and the
carrier board are
mounted in the back of
this big piece of wood
that I called the bezel here.
Just like most of the
rest of the hardware,
you can get to most of the
ports easily from the top,
and there's a little
access for the reset button
on the side, which is very
important when prototyping.
I want to point out here,
though that pretty much none
of these components
match the final hardware.
Obviously, as we've said,
the SoM is different.
So is the camera.
So are the mics.
So is the display.
But again, not an issue
because we're building Android
apps on this, and
they don't really
care so much about the
specific hardware underneath.
Building this prototype was my
favorite part of the project,
because at the time, the
deadlines were far enough away
so that they don't make
that crushing sound they do
when they get a little closer.
And we were still
a small team that
needed to be scrappy
and pretty resourceful.
So I literally built this case
in my garage over a few weeks.
And the best part of that is
that I got to buy a new tool.
Not just any tool, but a 60-watt
laser cutter, which of course,
I got off the internet.
I literally learned how to use
a laser cutter for this project.
I iterated on the
design in my garage
over the course
of a few weekends.
It was my first time using any
kind of 3D modeling package
to do this kind of design.
My first time ever
using a laser cutter.
And I basically learned
by watching videos online.
And the point here is that
if this is the kind of thing
you like, yes,
you can do it too.
And you'll probably have
a lot of fun doing it.
The material that I tried
first was this birch plywood.
It's about three
millimeters thick.
You can get it in quantity
from the net very easily--
two-day shipping, in
stacks of 25 or 60.
If you go for the
batch of 60, it's maybe
$1 and a half a sheet or less.
So it's pretty cost-effective.
When I first tried
building this out,
I wasn't very efficient
with my material use.
It would take maybe two
or three sheets of plywood
to build enough
parts for a case.
But eventually, you want to get
a little more optimized, waste
a little less material.
And as you see here, I
managed to fit the whole case
into a single 12-inch
square sheet of plywood.
I did have to fit one of the
sides inside of the bezel
to make that work.
It was a big challenge
to figure out
how to get this all into
one sheet of plywood--
a lot of fun to overcome that.
But laser cutters
only cut in 2D,
which meant it's a little
hard to work a fastener,
like a screw, into the design.
So this one is all friction fit.
I came up with a
tab and slot design
where you could put
it together by hand,
and it would stay
together pretty securely.
And the best part of that
was that it was actually real
easy to service in the field.
If a connector comes loose or
you need to change a jumper,
you can snap the thing
apart with your hands.
You don't need to
find a screwdriver.
You fix it.
You put it back together,
and you're good to go.
We tried a few variations
in other materials,
such as the acrylic
you see here.
I think it looks much
better than the wood.
Obviously, this semitransparent
red is really cool.
But what we found is that in
acrylic thickness-- for us
at least-- the material
we had, the thickness
varied too much across
color and even within color,
so that when we put some
of the cases together,
they just fall apart on a
desk, or they'd fit together
so tightly that
the acrylic would
snap at the weak
points, which turned out
to be the 90-degree
cuts in the material.
So we decided to go
with the wood after all
because it was going to
be more robust for us.
I cut about enough parts to make
about a dozen of these cases.
We brought them into the office.
I had some people
assemble them so
that we could try
out the design,
re-iterated on it a bit.
Eventually, settled
on a final design
and sent it off to an
internal shop at Google
with a laser cutter that
can cut these in bulk.
If you happen to
work for a company
that doesn't have a laser
cutter shop, not a big deal.
You can find plenty of
places on the internet where
you can upload your CAD files.
They'll cut them and
send them back to you.
If you've never worked
with a laser cutter before,
though, I recommend
you try one out
first before you send it off
and commit to a bulk order,
and get a feel for
what works and doesn't
work in this kind of design.
But again, the moral for
this part of the story
is that you can build
an enclosure too,
and laser cutters are cool.
So you should try one out.
Now, one more thing
before we move on, though.
I mentioned we wanted
to build a lot of these,
and we built 75 in the first
batch to spread around Google.
And we thought that was
going to be more than enough,
but they were so popular
that we built another 75.
And even that, frankly, we
could've used a bit more.
So once you have
this many devices--
and honestly, once you have
more than, say one or two--
you want a way to disambiguate
them to tell which one's which.
Because at some point,
someone will have a problem,
and they'll say, hey, man,
can you look at this device?
And you'll say, sure,
I'm busy right now.
Drop it off at my desk.
And maybe they'll put it next
to one that looks just like it
while you're away.
And then you end up
looking at the scorch marks
on the case to figure
out which is which.
So think ahead-- give each
device a serial number,
keep track of it in the
spreadsheet somewhere,
so you know how much inventory
you have left to give out,
or who's got what or
maybe what the history
of individual devices are.
SHIKHA KAPOOR: So we
now have the hardware
for a type 2 rollover
that application
developers for a short term.
In parallel, we were
working on finalizing
the SoM for smart displays.
We evaluate certain
options in our roadmaps
and kickstarted in
series of discussions.
Only this time, it was
with the SOC vendors.
They eventually selected
a Qualcomm SoM--
call this the SDA624 for the
Lenovo and LJNJBL devices
that are launching this year.
Partnering this is an eight-core
A53 with an Adreno 506 GPO.
That's a [INAUDIBLE]
display and camera.
It's plenty capable of
driving the smartest way.
And of course, a bunch of other
potential devices that you may
want to build as well.
On the SDA624, Google also
will offer free stability fixes
and security patches
for three years,
with options for
extended support.
To give you a more concrete
idea of the hardware
we are talking
about here, here's
a photo of the top of the SoM.
You can see the SOC, the Wi-Fi
Bluetooth module, the memory--
all mounted on a discrete board.
Here's the underside
of this SoM.
The main thing going
on here are those three
high-density connectors
with 100 pins each.
These bins make up the SoM's
interface to the outside world.
Here's a little deeper
dive into this home spinout
interface-- the pins
carry power, [INAUDIBLE],,
and a wide variety of peripheral
buses in and out of the SoM.
Wow, looks a little
overwhelming, doesn't it?
However, you wouldn't need
to worry about designing this
if you were using Android
Things to build your devices.
Pin assignment has
been standardized,
along with the
rest of this SoM so
that the underlying platform
know what the expectations are.
In some cases, you'll
also have the option
of laying out this arm circuit
flat onto your board exactly
as specified, according
to this interface.
However, it's much
faster and easier
to just build a carrier board
that this model can plug into.
ROBERT GINDA: So if you get
one of our development SoMs,
it'll come with our carrier
board that has some common I/O
pins broken out onto a
standard-sized header
so that you don't
need to deal with any
of these high-density
connectors.
But when you build a device
for real, for mass production,
you'll likely want to
spin your own carrier
board that connects
to whatever hardware
you need for your device.
For smart displays, we came up
with a reference carrier board
that we asked our
OEMs to follow.
You can see in the slide
here that in the middle,
we have the SoM, which
again is the CPU, the Wi-Fi,
and other important parts
and the peripherals are
connected around the outside.
We standardized on button
and sensor connections
in this reference
design, specifying
which GPIOs shows they should
connect into, for example,
to simplify our work
on the software side,
because we're working with
three OEMs simultaneously.
We wanted to avoid as much
as we could unnecessary
customizations across OEMs.
So everybody, for example,
plug their volume up
into the same GPIO on the SoM.
One other thing we specified
in the reference design
here is that the
microphone mute circuit
should be external to the SoM
and implemented in hardware.
So that when you
mute these devices,
the mics are electrically,
physically disconnected
from the SoM, so
that even in the face
of some sort of successful
software exploit in the future,
there is no way to unmute
the device and software.
Similarly, we specified as
part of the reference design
that the camera mute
should physically
cover the lens of the
camera so that there
is no way to unmute the camera,
so to speak, in software.
We did leave some room
for OEM customization.
For example, they could
select their own microphones.
They could build their
own audio output stages.
And they had some leeway
on display choice as well.
This is the next revision
of our development kit.
This is what came
after the wooden kits
that I showed earlier.
This one is built according
to the reference design.
And it's using a lot of
the production components
that we have in real devices.
This time around, the
entire front assembly
was put together
by an outside firm.
And we didn't have
to do any of that.
This case happened to be
in acrylic, as you can see.
It used friction fit grommets
to connect the standoffs
to the back.
These sometimes came loose
if you overtightened them,
but you could fix it with
a little bit of Super Glue
if you had to.
From the front, what we have
here is the exact same touch
panel, camera and, microphones
used in some of our production
devices.
We added this acrylic
back at Google,
which held the speaker in
place and really just gave
the front something to
lean up against so that it
was at a similar angle
to what we were expecting
for the production devices.
Inside, these are essentially
the Qualcomm SDA624 SoM
plugged into a
carrier board that
matches the reference design.
This is actually one of
the earlier versions,
which we called the FEP1.
And in these versions, the
amplifier and the display
interface were on
daughter cards that
plugged into the carrier board.
But on later revisions, we
had it all flattened down
onto a single carrier board.
We completed these
kits in the beginning
of December of last year.
If you're not
aware, CES is July--
sorry, June.
SHIKHA KAPOOR: January.
ROBERT GINDA: January.
January 9.
So we basically had
just a month to go
before the big show,
where we going to show off
these devices at CES.
So it was a little
nerve-wracking,
especially in those
weeks leading up
to the delivery
of these devices,
where the CES was getting
closer and closer.
But in fact, the
application engineers
had gotten off to a great
start with the wooden devices,
and we sorted out the platform
bring up on the Android Things
side relatively quickly.
So it was really kind of
amazing that one month
before this huge demo at CES,
we were able to completely swap
out the hardware.
We moved the entire
development team, platform
and, application engineers
from those wooden prototypes
over to devices running on
a completely different SOC
without a hitch.
And this is because thanks to
Android Things, a smart display
application is totally
independent of the platform.
You can see how this
was useful to us,
because we had this kind
of provisional situation
where we needed to bring
up temporary hardware
before the real stuff was ready.
But this can be really useful
in production devices as well.
You may ship this year,
with a certain profile,
a certain piece of
hardware that you need.
And then next year, maybe
you want to cost it down,
or you may want to
add new features
and switch to a more
powerful piece of hardware.
And because of
this, you can easily
reuse the application
software across a wide variety
of hardware platforms.
SHIKHA KAPOOR: So around
the same time as a reference
hardware was being completed.
OEM partners Lenovo,
JBL, and LG were busy
building out their own devices
based on the reference design
that we showed before.
Those arrived at Google
even closer to CES.
We got them with just about
two to three weeks to spare.
But again, the transition
was relatively smooth.
We hit a few bumps.
For example, on
one of our devices,
the camera looked green,
which we eventually
traced to a missing capacitor.
But essentially, nothing that
we couldn't sort out in time.
CES was a lot of work.
I remember cursing whoever
it is who schedules
it so close to holidays.
This is a picture
of our war room
that we set up a few
weeks before CES.
We spent a lot of time
here planning the demos,
adding features, and fixing
last-minute bugs on the device
and on the back end
servers that make it work.
On the demos, we planned
to show rich integration
with other Google services, such
as YouTube, Photos, and Maps.
This is a picture of
a little kid's room
that they set up in
Mountain View, which
had nice cameras
pointing at it, and we
could check in on a little
Android baby, all the way
from Vegas.
Our hard work and careful
planning paid off,
and the demos pretty much worked
like they were supposed to.
We had some issues setting up
the venue and a few hardware
glitches.
But we brought backups,
expecting that to happen.
The reception we got from
the press and users at CES
was very encouraging.
When you are hard at work
on something in secret,
it's hard to gauge how
the outside world is
going to react to it.
Getting this kind
of positive feedback
was a great shot of
motivation for the team
and helped further
galvanize the effort.
After CES, it was time to
get out of the demo mindset
and back to the
work of shipping.
At this point, we were
flush with hardware
from our OEM partners, and
the program was ramping up.
Up till now, we were handing
out a single software
build to all our developers.
But now we needed to expand out.
Fortunately, Android Things
makes this super easy,
using what we call as channels.
Our Developer Console allows
you to manage release and update
channels over time.
You can get a lot
more details on how
this works in Adam and
Amy's talk tomorrow.
So for Smart Displays, we
established multiple channels
for our internal user segments,
depending on their needs.
For example, our developers have
medium to high risk tolerance
and can replace
components as necessary.
We have a dev channel for them.
We also have a Canary for
high-risk tolerant developers
where we roll out daily builds.
Of course, we have a different
channel for our QA or testing
teams so that we can
give them early access
to builds that we want tested.
At this point, we also
have hundreds of Googlers
who are testing
out smart displays
and giving us
feedback on features.
These people need
more stable channels,
and they have low
risk tolerance.
So we roll out stable
weekly builds for them
with non-good functionality,
and we skip builds in case
there are issues.
We are getting close
to the end of the talk,
but I want to cover one more
thing before wrapping up.
In this day and age, if
you are shipping software,
you never really need to
be completely done with it.
If you are building a website
or a mobile application,
you can roll out bug
fixes whenever you want.
But when it comes to hardware,
you only get one shot at it.
Once it's in the hands
of the user, that's it.
There are some things that even
software cannot fix at that
point.
So you better get it right.
You also just cannot keep the
factory running continuously,
though making small
tweaks here and there.
You need to purchase your
building materials in bulk.
And since it's still
early in the process,
you're not going to be ready
to buy in mass production
quantities.
Also, the tooling and
testing takes some time
to set up and change.
So this process usually
happens across a few builds
that are standard in the
hardware development lifecycle.
You can read up more
about those on internet,
but I'll cover it briefly today.
So we already talked
about the prototype phase.
The next phase is the EVT,
or the Engineering Validation
Test.
For this phase, you are
trying to validate that you
got your schematics right.
You don't have
any layout issues,
and your components
work with each other,
the way they are supposed to.
If you are still considering
different design options,
you can iterate them.
This is a good time to do so.
This essentially represents
the first attempt
at building your boards
the way they will appear
inside your final device.
That enclosure is typically
still not final at this stage.
So you may want to keep the
board hard glued, screwed,
or taped, just to keep
them from flipping around.
The next stage is DVT, or
the Design Validation Test.
The purpose here is to verify
your production processes
and equipment to ensure
that they are meeting
your final specifications.
The devices we got for CES
were what we called as pre-DVT.
They were soft
tooled, which means
that the molds used
to cast the plastics
were made of a soft
material like silicone.
Again, you may want to
do a few builds here
until you get to a point
where you know that there are
no fixes that would need
the hardware [? respin. ?]
You ramp up quantities as
you get more confidence.
And eventually, you want to
get to a run with hard tool
plastics.
The PVT, or the Production
Validation Test,
is typically the last
build that transitions
into mass production.
Hopefully, by now, you've
logged in the final software
that you will be flashing
in on these devices.
At this point, you
are also hoping
that your factory's pretty
much running on autopilot,
without any manual intervention.
Finally, our product
is ready to go
to mass production, which means
its ready to be on shelves.
At this stage, you're
ramping up production
and focusing on making
process improvements
to improve the unit.
You obviously want to
continue testing it
for the next few months, though,
as well as establish some sort
of reliability testing.
So there-- that's how they build
smart displays from prototype
through production.
To reiterate, having
Android Things
as the underlying
platform helped
in every step of the way.
First, thanks to the
Android framework,
our software
developers could focus
on building application
features without having to worry
about the underlying platform.
Our System On Module,
or SoM, solutions
allowed them to swap out the
underlying hardware seamlessly
as we moved from one
prototype kit to the other,
without affecting that layer.
And yes, while we needed
it to do a lot of work
to bring up the SoMs
for smart displays,
you don't need to
do any of this.
The smart display SoM will
be ready for your use soon.
Our update in device
management features
allowed for fast iterations
and easy maintenance
of multiple devices
on the field.
And finally, our
security features
mean that OEM partners
and users don't
have to worry about the
security of these devices.
ROBERT GINDA: So we have a lot
more to show you at I/O. Come
and see us that
the Android Things
Sandbox Dome, which you can
see on the left side of the map
here.
The entire dome is filled
with Android Things demos,
and it's open after
hours as well.
You can see how we leverage
machine learning, Firebase,
and the cloud platform.
And you can also
have an up-close look
at the prototypes
and the devices
that we talked about here today.
By the way, you'll
notice Android Things
powered devices outside of
the Sandbox Dome as well.
There are survey
boxes all around I/O
that are built on
top of Android Things
and a large human-sized
robot roaming around,
ready to take a selfie with you.
So you can come to
our code labs as well,
shown sort of in the
middle area of this map.
We have code labs showing
how to work with TensorFlow,
how to work with
cloud IoT, and how
we made the survey boxes that
are around I/O, and even more.
There's seven more sessions
on Android Things coming up
today and tomorrow that
go even deeper into some
of these topics.
Finally, have some fun at I/O.
We have a scavenger hunt going
on, shown at the link
here g.co/iosearch.
I won't give away
too much, but you'll
run into some machine learning
enhanced flowers, which
are pretty cool.
And if you solve all the
puzzles and make it to the end,
then you'll get a piece
of developer hardware
to take home for yourself.
With that, I'd like to invite
you to go build some hardware.
And I hope that we're leaving
you with some new confidence
that you too can build a
device with Android Things.
Go to the link mentioned
here to get started today.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]